أطفال غزة الأعزاء أنا آسف لأن
العالم يرى دموعكم ويسمع
صراخكم ويرى أجسادكم مكدسة تحت
الأنقاض العالم يشهد ولكننا لا نزال
نسمع عن أحلامكم
وتطلعاتكم لتعلم السفر لزيارة
شواطئكم ذات المياه الزرقاء الصافية  أو
اللعب في الملاعب ذات المراجيح
والزلاقات ليصبحوا رواد فضاء ومدرسين
وأطباء وكل يوم نرى كيف أن تلك
الأحلام لم تعد موجودة قد تسأل العالم
أين كانت هذه القيم الدولية
للحرية والعدالة والمساواة عندما
لم يتمكن العالم حتى من حماية الحق
في  الحياة لطفل فلسطيني، قد
تسألون العالم لماذا كان هناك تحرك سريع
عندما كانت طرق التجارة والمصالح الاقتصادية
معرضة للخطر، ولكن الصمت يصم الآذان عندما
قُتل 10000 طفل عندما كان
ينبغي أن يكون العالم مصدر إلهام لكم،
وأصبحتم مصدر إلهام لنا.